right this is going to be really
up I actually think that people are
happy that you quit your job because it
counts you out of the race because the
likelihood that you win is so low and so
they're happy because you're actually
taking a step back you literally take a
step back in income take a step back in
status because you're not doing as well
like I went from a white collar job to
you know being a personal trainer like
it was a big step back so any of my peer
group were like oh yeah so good that
you're doing that right if I had
immediately jumped and started a tech
startup and raised $100 million they
probably immediately wouldn't have been
happy for me your success reminds them
of the dreams that they didn't to begin
with and that's why it's so hard to go
home for a lot of people or stay home
for a lot of people because everyone who
you grew up with in middle school and
high school you become a glaring example
of what they could have done but didn't
it's not your fault it's what you make
them think about themselves